allora abbiamo oggi innanzitutto
veramente ma richiesta un video con un
momento complicato perché volete
perdermi volete vedervi spese il magico
perché nipote muscolare per lui chi ha
perso tutto è possibile comunque abbiamo
comprato fa pesi un blog shopping di lol
sprite e mi avete detto di comprare il
gioco non street price è di provarlo
assieme abitare eccolo qua ho provato
eccolo qua non so se in italia sia
uguale penso di sì comunque in ireland
rai tutti qua c'è una piccola ball poi
ci sono degli accessori e non mi vedi
come si gioca andiamo ad aprirlo assieme
e anni ha molto carina e vitale
vediamo qui vince ma non mi voglio far
battere ovviamente primi commenti
ridotte fare tipo per un mero per vitale
e poi vediamo kindle anzi secondo voi
chi c'era in svizzera vitale vediamo chi
indovina al cuore palline si devono
mettere paletti fissati
qui abbiamo tutte le lodi con i numeri e
la presa e poi marito tramite cose che
stanno su questo piano del castello 10
essere il premio cinese non solo creare
dentro alle kakà real tavole como terrà
come premio ma va piazza tappa nel
tabellone quindi andiamo ad aprirla
adesso che ti ma cosa c'è dentro il 3
successo nota che carino allora diamoci
se la quarta volta che fa cadere
abbiamo letto le istruzioni è
praticamente matt damon da una pedina
che sarà una di questi tre girare questa
ruota co al centro e gli darà il numero
di cartelle poi quaindi catella c'è una
nuvoletta con scritto questa dobbiamo
fare pratica quando capiti insomma in
parte alla cartella se questi capita si
può aprire una delle sfere e pescare un
gettone da dentro tensione gettone
bumbuna si può prendere giunto nei
bambola che sarà una di queste love
price e c'è il colore in un gettone ad
esempio c'è il colore verde se hai
appunto che ho detto né bambola devi
collezionare tutti e sette i gettoni
dello stesso colore della l'on
quindi chi riesce per primo a
collezionare tutti i gettoni cissè tutti
7 gettoni del colore della propria non
vince non si è capito ma vedrete che
mano a mano che giochiamo si capirà
meglio e ovviamente fate tipo per me
vediamo chi vince
crediamo che l'old si capita tra l'altro
voglio questa glitterata moderata da
questa rosa allora todolì parte dice
tutto il giorno di loro e comincia la
zona è unicamente per gioco si avevano
più giovane che vi dimostro molte umana
mi riuscito in 212 cosa c'è scritto
nella casella venga un meccanismo questa
cartella poi sbirciare dentro una sfera
lol per vedere quali in gettoni contiene
senza che gli altri giocatori li web li
vedano poi solo guardare il lettore non
raccoglierli perché
infatti crede ma vabbè con qualcuno che
guarda video dai 4 2 3 e 4 unbox mi ami
vedere quindi io posso scegliere se
arrivi su questa casa e lascia in una
qualsiasi sfera lola da aprile guarda
tutti i gettoni sul terra se vuoi
prendine 1 ed asili di raccogliere
gettare posizionano solo strato
corrispondente del tuo segno punti
quindi prendine una casa degli e poi
sceglierne solo uno che deve essere una
voglio vedere e scegliere quello che
voglio ovviamente se c'è la holding
della volt non puoi iniziare a fare
punti se non hanno ovviamente io non so
affrontare e roberta per il kamarina
sarebbe meglio prendere la londra dell
interfaccia clinica ma devo per forza da
parte devono far vedere non è come
vedere un personal rai valoroso dubbio
ehi il tuo colore sarà il 100 e d'ora in
poi e celeste
io credo arola destro 022 unbox man mano
ok è un'aggravante
ecco qua la mia non scritte rata
quindi il mio colore sarà in giallo e
succedesse tiggiano quindi patetico
tentarlo 4 4 treni all'ora se arrivi su
questa cartella puoi scambiare i gettoni
che racconto con gli altri giocatori se
decidi accettare lo scambio posizione
gettone che ce ne fosse uno strato con
il fondente più come non abbiamo altri
settori cambiamo le niente no e appunto
a di tutto giù 5124 pc comasco sono
questo dono dio posso avere di 20 euro
come marocco una fonte anche per il
quale ebbe spin again televisi questa
carapella dino la peta e gioca un altro
turno questo credo a 3 1 2 1 buffon
guida parlando mi fa per sorprendere i
gettoni solo roma
ma ne possono prendere 10 mila va fatto
un punto che tocca a me sei 123456 cos'è
di nuovo tecnico solo guardata dunque
perna come avevo detto che vincevo io a
dando dentro questa vediamo ok un box
per una giornata è sempre vantato due
mondi zocchi allora io così quasi riapro
perché se non ricordo male ce n'era uno
che mi interessava si staglia prenderà
ora ciarla veramente si celebra domani
non ho capito che per me la baviera di
robot debolezze reti a 1 723 45 stesse
possono guardare con momentè
ma perché tu mi porti che questi giochi
non prendo io sono bravo nel gioco ma
guarda regolando che 5 1 2 3 4 cm che
[Applauso]
2 1 e 2 qual è fermi e niente 5 5 subiti
[Musica]
linguaggio ok visti anche questi sono
fortunato set con andrea 1234567 mix mix
mia ma cosa vuol dire dall'inizio è
stata sella poi mischiare tutte le sfere
love confondere gli altri giocatori con
un giorno no guardate tutte le crede che
chiaro e siccome io come memoria anche
il rischio perché sono dimentico io 53
allora protetta perché club portata
almeno il beneficio di averle quarta
sterline quasi sono ok premium vetta il
telefono giallo quindi comando con un
punto
browner cola finalmente stiamo simon 4
naturalmente sono 3 verona
quindi 1 2 3 e 4
quando questo la posso prendere questo
solo guardare e hanno se c'è qualcosa di
interessante molto bene lo devo solo
guardarla andamento opposto che per
caffè 5 2 3 4 5 di nuovo 3 1 2 3 ballare
thai boxing di questa che imprendo il
vestitino giallo
sono già tre punti 11 set
1 2 3 4 5 6 e 7 no teca fink possono
guardare da anni mancano solo 12 4 punti
e porte tosto dizione giro ragazzi forse
piccoli adorato dai 4 1 2 3 4
non cambia niente con la tela per
cambiare perché a me fermano tutte
queste 11 rischio perciò paura di
dimenticare le cose
3 1 2 o per fortuna adesso visto che non
mi ricordo governo che ho guardato male
no
trovato una gialla e ora per vincere mi
va canzone tre punti e li vediamo due io
bisogno questo di c 1 e 2
crispin again tra 12 e box
quindi io prenderei questa che ho
guardato recentemente molto bene fanno
vedere verde cioè sera per cento quindi
per tre punti trovino delle due visite
persona votato fin dall'inizio uno spin
again che mi devo girare nuovamente 53
e i nuovi skill a rischio tutto non
guardare come non contavamo guardare
sì sì sì 123456 ogni scarl è nuovamente
se voi tanto è bastato
accanto a tutto ci facciamo aiutata
dalla fortuna
06 12 34 56 giro di nuovo 3 1 2 3 a fare
la jovanotti con questa speriamo
soltanto che prenderà questa c'è un
perché il lunario fa sorprendere
quindi nel caso poi potrà solamente
scambiarlo faccia quindi se tu non
kamiko la reggiana non voglio iniziare
neanche 1.3456 per sempre surprise
questa casella puoi prendere un gettone
dando dei altri giocatori
ledger il preannunciato da un giocatore
o aprire una qualsiasi spera lord e
raccogliete al suo interno gettone che
preferisci sera con un gettone poi sono
solo strato presidente non ci posso
credere
ciao grazie non ci posso credere questo
giusta cospirato contro di me non è
possibile
sono in vantaggio quando te ne mancano
ancora 2 a 0 5
[Musica]
345 la fortuna di nuovo da me fatta il
controllo questa controllo e guardare
non guarda ad es
tutto bene quindi sostenuti riguardarli
barbè 212 posso fare l'unboxing con
questa premessa che prendo questa sera e
mi dispiace
un'altra del lettura di non puoi l'inter
entra di quella uno che ne esprime io
scusa questo sito ah sì quindi io sono
un fan box tv che fortuna guardare stato
associato perché se l'unica aperta prima
perché vedevo prandone per forza se vuoi
ma tanti sono inutili perché non te ne
20 maggio realtà neanche lì per ottenete
andiamo avanti 2 1 2 si era di nuovo 5 1
2 3 4 5
[Musica]
ciao ciao